a la izquierda imágenes de hace cuatro
años el entonces presidente colombiano
Iván Duque Acompaña a Juan guaidó en su
intento por entrar en Venezuela desde la
frontera de Colombia es el día en el que
se rompen relaciones diplomáticas con el
presidente Nicolás Maduro a la derecha
imágenes de hace una semana desde la
misma frontera maduro y el sucesor de
Duque el izquierdista Gustavo Petro
reactivan un acuerdo comercial
suspendido es el cuarto encuentro
amistoso entre los mandatarios desde la
llegada al poder de Petro el 7 de agosto
de 2022
fue el último paso en la normalización
de relaciones después de la reapertura
de la frontera cerrada desde 2015 el
regreso de Embajadores a Bogotá y
Caracas y el restablecimiento de la
conexión aérea
juro bien distinta Era la situación Hace
cuatro años Un mes antes Juan guaidó se
autoproclamaba presidente interino de
Venezuela y el 23 de febrero de 2019
lideró una caravana humanitaria de ayuda
desde Colombia para Venezuela allí
estaba el expresidente colombiano Iván
Duque y estas palabras detonaron la
ruptura diplomática quiero expresar que
Colombia
reconoce a Juan guaidó como presidente
de Venezuela y acompaña este proceso de
transición hacia la democracia para que
el pueblo venezolano se libere de la
dictadura desde ese momento todos los
vínculos oficiales se perdieron y
Colombia fue uno de los estados más
beligerantes contra el gobierno de
Nicolás maduro Duque declaraba que a
maduro le quedaba poco tiempo en el
poder ambos países comparten una
frontera de 2.200 km que durante mucho
tiempo fue considerada una de las más
vivas y dinámicas de América Latina con
cambio comercial que superó los 7.000
millones de dólares en 2008 ahora la
expectativa ambos lados de la raya
divisoria es que se restablezcan los
lazos no solo comerciales sino de
hermandad entre los dos países vecinos